hoy hablaremos sobre el cociente de
reacción q en este vídeo
me gustaría que veamos cómo calcular q y
cómo podemos usarlo empecemos con una
reacción
tenemos dióxido de azufre so2 gaseoso
que reacciona con oxígeno gaseoso y esta
es una reacción reversible que produce
dióxido de azufre
so3 y vamos a asegurarnos de que esta
sea una reacción balanceada aquí tenemos
dos moléculas de dióxido de azufre que
reaccionan con una de otros para
producir 2s o tres ahora al equilibrio
podemos calcular la constante de
equilibrio que hace entonces al
equilibrio sabemos que las
concentraciones deben de ser constantes
porque la velocidad de las reacciones en
una dirección y en la otra es la misma
así que si sustituimos estas
concentraciones en esta expresión nos
queda que casi es igual a la
concentración del producto
al cuadrado porque tenemos este
coeficiente este geométrico entre la
concentración de nuestros reactivos que
son s otros al cuadrado por la
concentración de todos ok
también sabemos que a una cierta
temperatura si sustituimos las
concentraciones al equilibrio casi es
igual a 4.3 pero qué pasaría si
quisiéramos analizar la reacción aunque
todavía no se encuentre al equilibrio o
tal vez simplemente no sabemos si ya
llegó al equilibrio bueno en ese caso si
no estamos seguros de que la reacción
llegó al equilibrio o incluso en
cualquier momento de la reacción lo que
podemos hacer es calcular el cociente de
reacción q entonces conoce es igual a la
concentración de nuestro producto al
cuadrado elevamos la concentración del
producto al coeficiente este geométrico
entre las concentraciones de los
productos también elevados a sus
coeficientes este geométricos entonces
tenemos s autos al cuadrado
y todos aquí en este momento quizás se
estén preguntando cuál es la diferencia
porque miren la ecuación de cruce y casi
se ven exactamente iguales pero la
diferencia es cuando las usamos miren la
constante de equilibrio acá se puede
calcular únicamente con las
concentraciones al equilibrio y en este
caso la cee significa que todo está en
términos de la concentración molar
mientras que para el cociente de
reacción que nuevamente todo está en
términos de concentración molar pero
esto lo podemos calcular con cualquier
concentración porque no necesitamos
encontrarnos al equilibrio concentración
molar
entonces calculemos esto para algunos
ejemplos de concentraciones supongamos
que en algún punto de nuestra reacción
tenemos las siguientes concentraciones
0.10 molar de so2 0.30 molar de o2 y 3.5
molar de nuestro producto entonces si
sustituimos estos números en la
expresión de cruce tenemos 3.5 molar al
cuadrado en el numerador y 0.10 al
cuadrado por 0.30 en el denominador y al
calcular esto con la calculadora yo
obtuve que cruce usando estas
concentraciones es igual a 4 mil 83 ok
ya sabemos cómo calcular couché pero
ahora veamos qué significa 1000 existen
tres posibles escenarios cuando q es
igual a k
eso significa que nos encontramos al
equilibrio entonces si en cualquier
punto de la reacción
no están seguros de si sus
concentraciones ya son las
concentraciones al equilibrio pueden
calcular q y corroborar si es igual acá
y en este caso no lo es así que las
otras dos posibilidades son que q sea
mayor acá que es nuestro caso o que q
sea menor acá entonces veamos estas dos
posibilidades
mire podemos dibujar todos los valores
posibles de q en una recta numérica que
puede tener valores en cualquier punto
desde cero hasta infinito y miren cuando
no tenemos nada de producto el numerador
sería cero y por lo tanto q sería igual
a cero entonces esto nos dice que q es
igual a cero cuando sólo tenemos
reactivos tenemos todos los reactivos y
nada de productos
y reactivos pero después si no nos queda
ningún reactivo pero todo lo que tenemos
son productos entonces tendríamos cero
en el denominador y por lo tanto el
valor de q sería infinito así que cuando
q es infinito solo tenemos productos
tenemos todos los productos
y después aquí tenemos un montón de
valores escribiré algunos valores
intermedios
todos estos valores son muy importantes
porque generalmente vamos a querer
comparar los valores relativos de cv y
de k
entonces en este caso q es igual a 4 mil
83 que lo pondré por aquí este escuche y
nuestra acá en amarillo es 4.3 podemos
decir que se encuentra por aquí entonces
podemos ver que nuestra q es más grande
que acá y está más cerca de donde
tendríamos todos los productos así que
para las concentraciones que tenemos
aquí arriba tenemos más productos de los
que necesitamos al equilibrio entonces
como nuestra reacción va a tratar de
ajustar las concentraciones para llegar
al equilibrio y nuestra recta numérica
eso significa que las concentraciones
van a cambiar para que que se acerque
más acá y como el cambio es hacia la
izquierda es decir en dirección hacia
todos los reactivos entonces la reacción
se favorecerá hacia los reactivos
alcanzar el equilibrio entonces si q es
mayor acá como en este caso se favorecen
los reactivos
reactivos
y por lo tanto cuando q es menor acá la
reacción se favorecerá hacia los
productos se favorecen los productos y
también podemos ver eso en nuestra recta
numérica entonces si tenemos diferentes
concentraciones y q es menor acá para
eso usaré este color
supongamos que ahora que tiene un valor
que se encuentra por aquí entonces ahora
el cambio sería hacia la derecha para
formar más productos y por lo tanto eso
significa que nuestra reacción tratará
de alcanzar el equilibrio favoreciendo
la reacción hacia la derecha así es cómo
pueden calcular q y así es como pueden
usarla para ver cómo cambiarán las
concentraciones en la reacción para que
alcance el equilibrio en el siguiente
vídeo veremos un ejemplo usando q y
trataremos de predecir cómo cambiarán
las concentraciones de los reactivos en
otra reacción